My name is Willow and this was
nuggets. Oh
Here at the prop gallery
2012. Uh the point of this workshop is
just to have nuggets a ploy. It's just
random fun things that I thought about
before the workshop to throw out in the
air so you can just catch them at your
will, decide what you like, and then
practice them if you want. So I won't go
into too much explanation for each of
them, but here we go. We have this
really simple way that I like to warm up
with the PO and orient myself just like
these little float patterns like that
one
and that one.
Fun. Got this double bicep top bounce
job.
I didn't really talk about it, but
there's another variation of this one to
touch underneath.
Okay,
good back and flat. Classic move this
here. Few turning around
different kinds of tosses there. That
second toss.
[Music]
Yep. This classical lumber here, it's
really challenging and fun.
Always tossing from the armpit behind
the back and catching behind the hip.
Doing this pattern in together position.
We have
covered a lot of this little stuff like
that one
and that one. We did these all as like
continuous patterns.
this
very necessary number.
Uh we showed it as a weave
to get going
and we need to this one as an all under
the leg situation.
Switch it. Handle head switch. Handle
head switch.
Also showed this version of this thing.
Go like that all the way around.
And then
Oh, I should just show this one. We'll
talk about it, but it's fun. Do the
other end around. That's the thing.
Okay.
You did
this move
hard.
[Music]
Uh economy of motion thing.
Okay, not going to explain too many
things.
Okay, we talked about this old real
move. Here we go. Shoulder body toss,
shoulder wrap, shoulder pass, body toss,
shoulder pass, body toss. Always keeps
you turning in one direction.
We did this little shot thing, which is
really weird.
And we did this little spin-off of
I think exploring cadence workshop
getting it on your arm instead then even
going and putting it on your non-native
side instead.
Um
we did catch stuff
head pointing backwards toss up the
point nicely avoid hurting your back. Do
all kinds of stuff with that. make it
look if you want to juggling with it.
Uh yeah, the other way is with the head
pointing forward, grabbing it with your
foot
up back there.
We
talked about wibbles. Wibble is this
thing.
And you can do it all over your body
[Music]
out.
Uh this thing cool thing
under the armpit
going for this negative space target to
fall through catching under this and
then head contact back.
Yeah. So you just put it in the middle
of your back. Flick that handle up. Jab
under your butt. Totally possible to do
this in the other direction.
And
yeah, that's it. Have fun with those
nuggets.